a davantage de violence, c'est
pas juste une impression, en
tout cas, en ce moment, si on
isole quelques semaines, il y a
eu plus de coups de feu etc.
Avec nous, Anie Samson et Luc
Ferrandez. Bonsoir. Luc
Ferrandez, est-ce que c'était
une réponse attendue? Il fallait
qu'elle se repositionne sur ce
sujet qui va être incontournable
dans la campagne : la sécurité
de Montréal.
- Absolument. Il faut constater
qu'il y a eu un changement de
cap. Pendant les deux dernières
années, deux ou trois dernières
années, c'est pas de ça dont on
parlait. On parlait beaucoup des
caméras corporelles, des
arrestations avec décès,
notamment auprès de personnes
souffrant de problèmes de santé
mentale. Une police plus
communautaire et plus
psychosociale. Ça évite la
question des gang de rue longs
qui sont en augmentation. On dit
qu'on va mettre plus d'argent.
Est-ce qu'il y a un programme ou
une façon de faire face aux
problèmes? On ne l'a pas entendu
encore.
- Anie Samson, il y avait des
gens qui avaient l'impression
après le congrès du parti de Mme
Plante qu'on allait vers, au
contraire, n'ont pas ratatiné la
police, elle s'en était
défendue, elle veut bien montrer
qu'elle prend sa politiquement.
- Politiquement électoralistes.
Si vous lisez bien l'article,
l'embauche des 42 policiers va
être en vigueur l'année
prochaine. On annonce
aujourd'hui en grande pompe qui
avoir 5,5 millions et que le
problème va se régler, mais pas
aujourd'hui. C'est comme les
pompierqui vont éteindre, et non
pas les outils, et on leur dit :
l'année prochaine, on va vous
donner les outils. Il est trop
tard. Le feu est pris dans la
cabane. On est en campagne
électorale, c'est pour ça que ça
sort. C'est maintenant qu'on
doit agir avant qu'il soit trop
tard. Il est minuit -5 dans ce
dossier. Il faut le prendre au
sérieux. Lorsqu'on parle de
police, c'est pour défendre la
population. Les gang de rue ont
décidé de prendre la place. Les
armes, il y a une des
responsabilités qui n'est pas
juste à la ville ou à la police,
mais aussi à la justice.
Actuellement, quelqu'un qui est
pris avec une arme à une peine
ridicule, pas assez pour faire
peur aux jeunes de se promener
avec des armes à feu. Il va
falloir que la société au
complet sans mail. L'écosystème
provincial, fédéral, c'est
l'affaire de tout le monde, pas
juste l'affaire d'une ville.
- Ce qu'on a entendu y haver que
ce sont des relations publiques?
- Tout à fait. Depuis 1990, la
criminalité a chuté à Montréal,
plus de la moitié de diminution
de la criminalité dans presque
tous les domaines. L'an passé,
ça a augmenté dans un domaine
très précis de la possession
d'arme à feu et de l'usage des
armes à feu. Mais ça a diminué
dans le monde du crime. On n'a
pas problème d'une ville
violente, on a un problème de
gang de rue violent. Ça nous
arrive pas jusqu'à nous. Par
exemple les deux pays. Je disais
aujourd'hui, en Suède, social-
démocrate où il y a peu ou pas
de violence dans le reste de la
population, mais au niveau des
gang de rue il y a plus de
violence. C'est un problème lié
au gang de rue. Et à la
possession d'armes. Le maire et
la mairesse, qui qu'il soit, ne
va pas pouvoir régler ce
problème facilement dans les
mois qui vont suivre par
l'embauche de 40 personnes. Il
va falloir mettre en place des
programmes de surveillance, des
programmes communautaires, des
programmes de présence
policière. Il va falloir se
positionner sur les outils de
surveillance on va se donner. Il
faut faire pression pour avoir
les modifications sur les peines
qui sont apportées à ces gens.
Il faut faire pression sur le
fédéral et sur la possession
d'armes de poing. Ce n'est pas
le fait qu'on met 40 personnes
qui va régler le problème demain
matin.
- À l'et Longueuil, agrandissant
le cercle. D'après aussi. Le
chef de police est plus agressif
dans les médias pour dire : on
fait quelque chose.
- Il y a des solutions.
Longueuil est un des plus beaux
exemples. Longueuil a reçu un
prix des chefs de police
canadienne sur sa façon d'agir
avec les gens. Quand il y a une
fusillade à Longueuil? Une, et
c'est quelqu'un de Montréal qui
est allé là-bas. Pourquoi? Il y
a des programmes de prévention.
En politique, ce n'est pas
payant, en campagne électorale,
on annonce de la prévention...
mais sur le terrain, dans les
années qui suivent, on a des
résultats. C'est ce qui s'est
passé. La prévention, la
proximité des policiers. Il a
envoyé les policiers dans la
rue, voir les citoyens, les
jeunes, aller parler aux gens.
C'est à ça que servait la police
de proximité à Montréal.
Rencontrer les gens et créer des
climats de confiance pour
échanger avec. Tant qu'on ne
remettra pas ses barrières...
- il y en a un peu.
- Beaucoup moins. Ce n'est plus
populaire, la prévention. On a
manqué le bateau.
- J'aimerais entendre le maire
de Laval, à peine sorti de près
il y a quatre jours avec son
chef de police sur
l'augmentation du nombre de cas
à Laval. 30 événements avec arme
à feu depuis le début de
l'année, c'est gigantesque. Il y
a eu un livre qui a été déposé
par le SPVM en disant : on va
faire une fusion des police de
Longueuil, Laval et Montréal. Ça
a été refusé.
- Ça n'arrivera jamais.
- Effectivement. On veut une
police de proximité. Un instant.
Il y a eu une fusillade dans un
bar à Longueuil en 2016. Où a
été retrouvé le criminel? À
Calgary. Il n'a pas été retrouvé
à Longueuil. À Laval, c'est
pareil. Les armes de poing qui
circula circule dans toute la
région de Montréal, passe par
les réserves... Kahnawake, par
exemple, elles sont distribuées
par d'autres moyens. En pièces
par la poste. Est-ce qu'une
police de Longueuil ou Laval
peut régler des problèmes comme
la traite de personnes et la
possession d'arme à feu toute
seule juste sur son territoire?
- Poser la question, c'est y
répondre. Non. Il faudra voir,
je reviens à Montréal, les deux
candidats principaux, Mme Plante
et M. Coderre ne vont pas se
démarquer dans leurs
propositions. Ça va être plus de
policiers?
- Ça va être plus que ça, si tu
me permets. Il va falloir un
plan d'action concret. On ne
peut pas juste mettre des
policiers. Il faut aller à la
racine, à la base.
- On se quitte sur une note
positive. L'esplanade
tranquille, on l'a attendu
beaucoup. J'avais fait une vie
quartier l'an dernier là-dessus.
Les gens se demandaient : c'est
bien long. Avez-vous été mêlé
dans ce projet?
- Oui. À un niveau, ce n'est pas
moi qui avais les mains dans la
pâte Christine Gosselin. C'est
passé au comité des grands
projets. J'avais été émerveillé.
Ce qu'ils vont construire, ce
qu'ils ont construit, c'est un
bâtiment long qui vient couper
un mur aveugle a